oh my goodness i would say
hey guys i'm gonna unbox something
exciting for you today but it's already
here i already unboxed it and it is
sitting on my desk today we're taking a
look at the xbox
series x and the new xbox series
s i have to say it very slowly because
every time i say it fast
my homepod thinks that i'm saying hey
these are just display models so they're
not actually working but these
are a full-size replica of what the
actual devices
will look like and i could not be more
excited the series x
is 4.99 and the series s is 2.99 and
they are both available on november 10.
i think a lot of people were expecting
xbox to obviously do a smaller console
that is more cost efficient but i think
one of the things that we didn't think
was it was going to be out at the same
time
as the actual series x so let's just
take a look at them
side by side so the s is digital only
and this does have a storage
up to 512 gigs and the x has storage up
to one terabyte and these do have
expansion slots
so you will be able to expand the
storage up to one terabyte
when i first opened these i was kind of
shocked because i actually thought that
both of them
would be a lot larger than they were
this s
is so small it does have a lot of
ventilation both on the top and on this
little it kind of looks like a camping
stove like this that's kind of what i
see
and it does have these little leggies
right here
on both one side and on the bottom oh it
even has some ventilation there too so
depending upon how you
want to place this actually that's a
perfect size
so you could have it here or you can
have it like
this let's take a look at the backboards
we've got ethernet two usb hdmi this is
the storage expansion slot
and i imagine this is where the power
supply will go
to power the whole device sync it's got
a nice usb port on the front
power button it does not work but
very soon it will well not in this
device this is not real there's nothing
in here
it's crazy how light it is because
there's nothing inside of it so it will
be interesting to see
the weight when there's actually
components inside of it so very similar
to the s we have hdmi
power expansion slot two usb ports and
ethernet ventilation on the back there's
ventilation on the top
and on the bottom here's a really cool
example of the airflow to keep the
console cool and quiet it also has a
split
motherboard which is the first time ever
on a console this allows for even
temperature control for more output
power
i'm definitely excited for next gen
consoles but i think what's interesting
is the fact that they did decide to
launch both of these side by side the s
is quite interesting because microsoft
was taking into account that most people
would prefer to have higher frame rate
as opposed to
4k gaming so with that the s was born
and here it is this really is just a
quick little video to show you guys what
these actual devices will look like
in the wild when you finally do get them
something else that xbox has been doing
a great job of
is the integration of game pass with
game pass ultimate you can play
on a mobile device pc and even
on your consoles so i would love to know
what you guys think
i feel like on twitter a lot of you guys
were of course
very vocal the console wars the pc
master race
just play what you want to play just do
you do you like playing video games
i don't care what you play on you want
to call me an xbox fan girl
here let me give you a little more feel
to that fire this is
the advanced warfare xbox one this thing
is beautiful i mean just
look at this look at this stuff isn't it
neat what did you think my xbox
collections
what oh complete it's not because we
also
have my other favorite one this is the
xbox 360 star wars edition
can you just look at this this also has
a c3po
controller and it is it's so cool
normally if i do have other xboxes like
this i will either donate them
or give them to friends these are the
xboxes that i've kept in my collection
because they
are my favorite or they have sentimental
meaning this was the
ombre xbox this was the one that taco
bell sent out
a while ago like last year it just looks
pretty awesome
also one of my favorites this is the
gears
exclusive xbox one x this one has so
many details and i love that they
really went for it i mean there's like
cracks some texture and design as well
and xbox one s this is the one that i
really wanted to compare
the size to for the s there was also an
xbox one s digital version
this is not the digital this has the cd
slot i did have a really cool
gears 360 xbox but that actually went to
my grandmother we did upgrade her to an
xbox one at some point
i mean i don't know how many of your
grandmothers have consoles that are just
i'm sure some i actually my audience i
know you i'm sure you guys have
grandma's that
that have consoles so we're on the same
page here okay i'm going to stack these
up
over here just wow that is that xbox one
x is
beefy the 360 design
it's pretty good xbox one s in
comparison to the xbox
series s it's so small like look at this
are you seeing this tiny
small
i mean this in comparison to it's
even it's kind of hard to even compare
it like how do you uh
because this is such a new form factor
like xbox hasn't really done
anything in this kind of i mean it's
like a
it's like a big rectangle you can
display it either
vertical or horizontal i'm curious to
see like what most people
decide is the way that they're going to
use this i want to compare this though
to the xbox
one because that oh my god there's so
many i'm so
weak oh geez oh that's probably like
like we want to say that like this is
big this is
basically this but squished it's shorter
i really think if you kind of just
squish this down it would be the same
thing
i don't even know what the best way is
to show the size comparison can you tell
there's a connect port connect
oh rest in peace one more thing
sea of thieves now has dogs in the game
and they sent out this cute little press
package
i wasn't gonna unbox this but as soon as
i opened it up it was so cute i had to
i'm gonna take this off and put it on my
dog's cage this is a very cute box
this is awesome a small scroll
if you will oh
this is nice too it's a little like
wax seal this is super cute
sea of thieves now offers pirates their
chance to sail the seas with a canine
companion
but even the inside of the box
cute the details banana apple and
blueberry dog biscuits
oh it's actually for a dog it's not for
human consumption when communicating
publicly about microsoft xbox
relationship
so i have to disclose that i have not
received compensation but this is a free
product that i have received
from microsoft so thank you they all
they told me to use easily understood
language
okay well i think you guys understood it
oh my god i think we have found some
treasure
oh look at this this is so
cool if you guys don't know i love
skulls i have them all around my house
it basically looks like halloween here
all year round so this is awesome oh my
god there's a game code on the inside
oh look at these these bags are so cute
what a cool press kit thank you
microsoft for sending this
i love sea of thieves it's such a fun
game do you guys remember when i had to
see atheist birthday party
two years ago happy birthday i
justine do you guys get it so i would
love to hear from you guys what do you
guys think of these consoles i'm sure
there's gonna be a big war
in the comments which is not really
welcome but you guys are gonna do it
anyway so
who am i to tell you what to do make
sure you guys subscribe and like this
video and hit the bell so you'll be
notified when
a new video comes out and i've got a lot
of really great videos coming out
very soon so stay tuned i'm excited it's
official
gaming season it's in session
i feel like this whole year is actually
one gaming season because we can't leave
the house or do anything else so gaming
season
[Music]
upgraded